nein sowas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen beim ein video ja heute was
geht ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich habe
mir für heute mal was ja wie soll ich
sagen ich weiß nicht genau was da auf
mich zukommt ich bin die letzten auf
diese idee gekommen und hab mir gedacht
das könnte eigentlich ganz witzig werden
weil so was habe ich im kompletten raum
youtube noch nirgendwo gesehen und zwar
die idee ist folgende hier mein lieber
mitbewohner
jetzt gehts wirklich ihren kunden dann
lande
[Musik]
wir sind ja an sich relativ viel auf
youtube unterwegs und ich kenne auch
eigentlich fast alle etwas größeren
youtube aus deutschland und der liebe
juli hat sich jetzt fünf namen
herausgesucht und die wird er mir gleich
einfach so als ich habe gar kein plan
weder durch rauch gesucht für die mir
einfach gleich heraus ballack und ich
muss so in 30 sekunden oder so einfach
meine meinung zu diesem youtuber sagen
und ich muss halt wirklich ehrlich sein
und es dann auch wirklich hoch laden
sie wird nichts geschnitten voll meine
meinung und ich hoffe es fühlt sich
niemand angegriffen wenn auch mal das
eine oder andere schlechte wort fällt
wird so an sich kann man daraus der weg
schmiere volk machen deswegen männer das
feiert und bot auch noch eine folge mit
sagen bei 12.000 leicht machen dann
würde ich sagen
auf die plätze fertig ich anfangen soll
so an sich mag ich überhaupt nicht also
leute ich kenne natürlich alles was er
macht und ich an sich fand ich immer
früher witzig aber in letzter zeit so ab
und zu schaue ich da mal rein und ich
fünf einfach irgendwie ja nicht so gut
also der content ist halt das ist so
schwer sein dass viele dinger verbieten
27 als auch keinen fall mein typ
er habe ich jetzt was falsches gesagt
oder war das noch was
die verstörte bist wer du hast diese
views meine jungs nicht haben millionen
und können davon irgendwann meiner villa
kommt also an die ganzen leon marseille
fans nimmt wenig übel ist nur meine
meinung
youtube nach ein junge also irgendwie
bäckermeister bekommt man negative
folgen also an sich kann man nichts
gegen sagen machtvoll sein leben seine
videos sind jetzt nicht meine lieblings
videos und wechseln nicht aber noch
etwas wie der junge das ist so schwer
du weißt du du musst entwickelst du
wirklich überlegen also gegen seine
videos kann nicht sagen
machtvoll sein ding finde ich gut ja
aber es gibt auf jeden fall youtuber mit
denen ich mehr anfangen kann und die mir
gegenüber auch liegt
okay wir haben uns über die ganze hier
gefallen wird ich kann mir immer wieder
junge das ist kein youtube
natürlich kann ich auch sagen keine
ahnung ich kenne ihn nicht privat ich
hab noch nie auch glaube ich habe ich
meine hallo gesagt wird
die musik ist an sich gar nicht mal so
schlecht auf jeden fall würde ich sagen
gut produziert und ich finde ihn jetzt
nicht schlecht so erben cooles
installiert dass man zwar sagen aber das
ist kein youtube
das ist kein youtube okay
also ich muss erstmal sagen baby respekt
vor allem was du so alles geschafft hast
geil aber ich verstehe ich warum jedes
seiner videos voll mit werbung ist
wirklich in zehn minuten video ist acht
mal werbung das kann man doch nicht
machen da hat man doch ein schlechtes
gewissen oder nicht und ansonsten ist
das auch echt oftmals so offensichtliche
geldmacherei er ist das finde ich nicht
gut also ich weiß mir selber mal die
lupe kaufen das auch gebraten
falls ihr das noch nicht gesehen hat er
längst in der video beschreibung aber
ich hab manchmal also sogar ich fühle
mich schlecht wenn ich ein video von bbc
und siehe da schauen sich gerade so
viele kleine mädels das an und geben dir
dadurch so viel geld weil die fünf mal
werbung in einem zehn minuten video hat
und jedes video einfach zehn minuten
geht
da blutet mein herz wenn erst die gleich
noch mal ich weiß nicht vielleicht
siehst du das ja vielleicht haben meine
videos
ich habe an sich dann hab ich die klappe
vor einem halben jahr oder so habe ich
mal noch mal mit mir irgendwie kontakt
gehabt
ich finde es eigentlich schade dass man
so gar keinen kontakt mit klar das war
früher ein bisschen scheiße und du hast
mich auch gleich bei installiert warum
weiß ich nicht aber schöne grüße
vielleicht sieht man sich ja noch mal am
ende nicht nur nein hören wir auch
nahezu dem gleichen lied hey leute ohne
spaß das war wirklich schwerer als
gedacht man sitzt ja so und hat weg für
diese 30 sekunden und muss sich so voll
überlegen was man sagt weiland ich habe
jetzt zu keiner irgendwie durchgehend
positives gesagt oder setzten jetzt mal
so einen vorgreifen wie julian schmahl
sagen können wo stehe ich richtig hinter
oder dinge der weiß ganz genau
inwiefern ich zu leuten stehe und
deswegen hat er die halle genommen ja
etwas 105 youtuber glaube ich ich würde
sagen schreibt arbeiter in die
kommentare
juli dann kann er mir die bei der
nächsten folge nennen falls sie danach
bot drauf hab ich fand ihn irgendwie
ganz gut
seine kommentare wie es für netzwerk
facebook und den facebook für facebook
siehst du können sie eigentlich auch mal
wieder vorbeischauen checkt netze
dienste ab und wir sehen uns morgen um
14 uhr kommt das nächste video schaut
auf jeden fall reinhardt rein